With deciding on regular blood work, what should I choose?
Typically, it depends on your case.
So everybody is going to be different as far as what I would recommend for blood work.
But in general, everybody should be getting a CBC with differential.
That's a complete blood count with differential and a comprehensive metabolic profile.
I'm a standard metabolic profile.
Lots of times if you go to your doctor or let's say you have Medicare,
they're going to run the cheapest blood work as possible.
Ask for a comprehensive metabolic profile.
If I haven't done record, if I have an order of blood work on somebody before
and looked at their thyroid, typically when I order the blood work
or also order a complete thyroid panel,
because we want to differentiate between somebody who has, you know,
either a very hypo thyroid condition that has never been diagnosed
and or a Hashimoto's that has never been diagnosed,
versus somebody that's having a lot of fatigue from an anemia.
So anemia obviously is very common with cancer, but many cancer patients,
the diagnosis cancer have never actually had complete blood work
to even diagnose whether they had a comorbidity of low thyroid issue.
So I always like to screen for that and rule that out once we see that
that is within normal range than typically the second blood work that I'll order
for a person that I would omit that, and I might run some other tests.
Also, if you have cancer and you haven't had tuber markers done,
then running a tuber marker panel can be valuable.
If you're a female, obviously the female or the male tuber marker panel
added to that as well.
That would be just general blood work that we would look at
that would give us clues that I have made a lot of videos and blog posts
about a lot of those markers that you'd find in that panel,
in those panels that I just discussed and what they would mean.
If you want more information on tuber markers,
then you can look up the blog post on tuber markers,
and there's an exhaustive information on that and videos on that as well.
But obviously there's a lot of other blood work that could be run to help
diagnose a different conditioner to help figure out something else that's going on as well.